Speaker 1: I have for you today one
of those stories that gosh darn it,
it's sort of a feel good story. Somebody did
something great, and we can be glad about that.
But it's something great that was only necessary
because of how dystopian circumstances are in
the United States. What do I mean? You'll see as
soon as I give you the details? Headline Stacey
Abrams. We like Stacey Abrams pack wipes out two
hundred and twelve million dollars in medical debt
for one hundred and eight thousand people. Wow,
what a beautiful thing to do. Newsweek writes,
a political organization led by Stacey Abrams,
has paid off the medical debts owed by one hundred
and eight thousand people in five states. The
Fair Fight Political Action Committee donated
one point thirty four million dollars to the
nonprofit organization. Rest in peace medical debt
to clear debts that carried a face value of $212
million. The state where the most people received
the payoffs was Georgia. 69000 people had medical
bills paid, twenty seven thousand Arizonans
had their debts, paid 8000 Louisianans and 2000
Mississippians and Alabamians have had their debts
paid, Abrams says. I know firsthand how medical
costs and a broken health care system put families
further into debt, et cetera, et cetera. What a
beautiful thing to do, but this is another one of
those feel-good stories, and it is a great thing
that Stacey Abrams PAC did. It's a great thing.
Unburdening people of medical debt in this
way. These are stories that should not exist.
Remember that show Breaking
Bad? Arguably one of the best
dramatic television programs in history, I would
argue I would put it up there with any other show
that is a show whose premise wouldn't work in
Canada. It wouldn't work in Denmark, right?
Teacher gets sick with cancer and
starts making and selling meth
to pay for his medical treatment. You understand.
And then this reminds me, of course, of little
Johnny did a bake sale to raise money for a little
Emily's cancer treatment. How lovely. Shouldn't be
necessary, dystopian that it even exists in
one of the richest countries in the world.
So with all of these stories, I sort of repeat
what has been my perspective for a long time.
We can find the actions of individuals admirable
while finding the circumstances that precipitated
them disgusting and immoral. And that's exactly
what we have here. You know, you talk to people
in other countries, medical debt. What what do you
mean, medical debt? What does that mean, exactly?
And in many countries, particularly
countries that are as rich as ours?
Medical bankruptcy is not a thing. Medical debt
in this way is not a thing. And Stacey Abrams
is throwing millions $1.3 million to pay off
what was $212 million of face value of medical
expenditures for over hundred thousand different
people. She's great. What was done is fantastic
shouldn't be necessary. And just another signal
about how broken many of our systems are at this
point in time. I would love to hear from you about
it if your perspective is different. Let me know,
but admirable individual actions based on
completely horrifying circumstances beyond
Stacey Abrams control. Stacey Abrams is working
within the system to try to improve circumstances
for different people. OK. Next week, I want to
let everybody know we are going to be on alert
for the verdict in the Kyle Rittenhouse trial. The
case is going to the jury. We've been covering it
for a while. I just want to let everybody know
it's conceivable because sometimes you only get
an hour to 90 minutes notice that the verdict has
been reached. My intention is to cover that live.
We've been covering the trial daily since the
start, and I really want to make every effort
to kind of complete that, depending on when it
happens Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday. We don't
know how long the jury is going to deliberate.
It could be two weeks. We just have no idea.
It may throw off when some of the shows over
the next couple of weeks are published. So I'm
just asking for you from you for a little bit
of latitude. As far as that goes going forward,
in terms of the schedule upcoming, we're going to
be here all of next week, the following week. It's
Thanksgiving week here in the United States. We
will only be doing a Monday, Tuesday and Wednesday
show will run repeats on Thursday and Friday. But
we will be doing a short week Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday and then we'll be back with everything
else, normal, et cetera. One other programing note
we don't usually promote interviews ahead of time
because it happens maybe one out of twenty one out
of 18 guests bails at the last second. And that's
why we often don't promote interviews in advance.
Dozens and dozens of you said, Please talk to
Andrew Yang about his third party. We are going
to be we the we are actually. We're recording
the interview with Andrew Yang in the next week.
But it is scheduled to air on November 23rd. OK,
so the second to last show before Thanksgiving. We
are planning to have a wide ranging interview with
Andrew Yang. We will talk about the forward party.
We will talk about a lot of different things. If
you have things you want me to ask. Andrew Yang
about, you can email info at David Pakman dot com
and let me know. So with that, we'll take a quick
break. Let me know your thoughts where you are on
the Rittenhouse trial. You can find me on Twitter
at David Pakman. And we're going to be back with
your calls. I'm going to go over your emails.
We've got a lot of other things to discuss on this
tremendous Friday show. Remember that the David
Pakman show is primarily sponsored by folks who
sign up on my website, join Packman dot com would
love for you to grab a membership. We do an extra
show every day for those very folks and would
love to talk to many of you on the bonus show
comments as well. So sign up at join Packman Gqom.